it's here good old-fashioned dumpster
fire Demi Burnett is clapping back at
accusations she pulled a Jed during a
bachelor in paradise but now that I am
giving other people a chance and
particularly Derrick and I'm still
thinking about her backstory Demi opened
up to her new love interest Derrick peth
about her relationship with a woman
on Tuesday night's episode of bi P the
pair were getting close on the beach
before her reveal and Derrick took it
like a champ in full support of Demi I
don't want you to think that this
changes like something between us like
I'm so very much interested in
what I appreciate you
I can't imagine what's been going
through your heads now she's defending
herself in real time against a bachelor
nation comparing her to Jed Wyatt in a
sense deleted tweet bachelor in paradise
alum Tanner Talbert pointed out that
both Demi and Jed were dating other
people before they joined their
respective shows et exclusively spoke
with Tanner where he defended his
comments quote the JED comparison was
probably the most extreme I could have
gone but I don't regret it
adding Demi is fully hypocritical I have
100% heard from multiple people that she
planned an engagement I have been dating
a woman back home
I do miss her and I think about her all
the time and I am like so in with her
but like trying to come here and figure
out stuff about myself though demi was
not having Tanner and others comparisons
at all tweeting this not-safe-for-work
response quote Oh Goff not the same at
all maybe I can teach you a thing or two
about going down on your wife Tanner in
response to that Tanner told et the
comment was quote lowbrow I didn't feel
like it was an exclusive thing I was
dating around and it never felt like a
relationship to me let's rewind a little
further jed got engaged to Demi's bestie
Hannah brown during her season of The
Bachelorette and his relationship with
his girlfriend Haley Stephens made a
splash in the news as it was revealed
while Hannah's season played out my
heart gets broken a lot for a lot of
different reasons Hannah took to Twitter
to weigh in on the situation writing one
is my best friend and one is my
ex-fiance I can tell you firsthand not
the same I really don't know like what I
want and that's what I'm trying to
figure out
and I don't want to hurt anybody I want
to do what's going to make my heart the
happiest source close to the situation
that tells ET that Demi and Derek are in
a good place and he would defend Demi on
any of this the source says Derek
doesn't feel the comparisons of Demi to
Jed are fair quote Derek feels like Demi
has always completely told the truth how
did things go for you paradise was
amazing it was so fun so emotional but
ultimately all worth it very very good
so much fun
[Music]